I would like to say that I am very
pleased to be here today particularly
with two of the principals of our story
and I should share with you something
that comes from my wife when I told her
that I was gonna be on this book tour
she gave me a really good piece of
advice Joelle said don't try to come off
being super knowledgeable intellectual
and sophisticated just be yourself so on
that basis I will be myself and what I'd
like to do is very briefly tell you
about the book and I mean briefly and
then I turn it over to Mary Dunham
Nichols who in fact is one of the
principals in the book and a heroine in
her own right and Carlos E Campbell who
flew the missions who was an
intelligence officer in the Navy and
who's got a lot of first-hand experience
in this situation and Carlos in fact has
been jumped by MiG's several times but
that's getting ahead of the story this
book grew out of another book called
deep black space espionage and national
security which I researched in the
mid-1980s and during the course of
researching the book and was about spy
satellites reconnaissance satellites I
learned that Francis Gary Powers a brave
and wonderful individual was the tip of
the iceberg in fact more than a hundred
and thirty Americans died or were made
prisoner during the Cold War flying
reconnaissance missions against the USSR
and communist China North Korea and
Vietnam and the Eastern European bloc
and this is a story that basically had
not been told it was classified
top-secret throughout many of the wives
did not know in fact most of the wives
had no clue exactly what their husbands
were doing
wound up in terms of the people who were
missing getting telegrams saying we
regret to inform you in the case of a
woman named Gino Kelly whose husband
died in 53 we were gret to inform you
that your husband is reported missing on
a routine training flight near Japan
well hey it wasn't near Japan it was in
Vladivostok Harbor ferreting radar and
beat was anything but a routine training
flight so there was a lot of pain there
was a lot of suffering and what I came
to find that during the research there
were questions that weren't being
answered by the government and a curious
anomaly developed I've been a lifelong
airplane buff going back to high school
I never knew a Ford from a Chevy but I
knew every airplane that had ever been
ever been made and I knew when I read in
the paper that such and such an our b-29
a reconnaissance airplane that was
missing near the Soviet Union probably
had run into trouble but one could never
prove it until recently but that in fact
is what was going on the anomaly was I
would go to the movies during the Cold
War and I would see these wonderful
movies about the fighter and the bomber
people I remember Strategic Air Command
with Jimmy Stewart his adoring wife was
played by June Allyson
I remember the McConnell story about
James McConnell our original top scoring
Korean War ace whose adoring wife was
played by June Allyson had typecast if
ever an actress was but these people got
a lot of credit they got a lot of the
glory and in fact during the Cold War
what they did was practice will amaze
fatigue Air Command practice bombing
targets behind the Iron Curtain and the
fighter people in the Air Force for
example had their exercises every year
and they got trophies William Tell was
one red flag was another and so on I was
astounded to find out that the people
who were actually getting killed were
the reconnaissance intelligence people
and they worked under absolute secrecy
and could not in any way reveal what
they were doing and I resolved that
wanted to try to rectify that and to
rectify the fact that they were never
given anywhere near the credit that no
credit publicly that they would do and
in fact we're an embarrassment when they
failed and there were 16 major shoot
downs between 1950 and 1969 Air Force
and Navy and as I say well over a
hundred of these guys disappeared some
were killed and some with add question I
have found out were captured and we
tended to walk away from it as somebody
pointed out in the Eisenhower
administration this was a problem
without a solution if Dwight Eisenhower
had gone public and said you have the
Khrushchev you have got our Airmen and
the Democrats would have said and
president went what are you going to do
to get them back so the prudent thing to
do was to sweep it under the rug
don't admit you were doing
reconnaissance against the Russians you
don't want to embarrass them and so on
and so it went under the rug now it is
still under the rug and the reason is if
somebody put it very nicely originally
it was under the rug because the
Russians were enemies and now it's under
the rug because the Russians are our
friends they need us for economic
reasons we need them for political
reasons nobody wants to publicize the
fact at the KGB and the GRU captured and
brutalized an American airman during all
those years so again the book is a
people book the missions are in there
the planes are in there the machinery is
in there but it's a book about human
beings and on that note we've got two of
them
I am honored to say we've got two of
them here right now one of them being
Mary Dunham Nichols who has got our own
incredible story to tell about her
husband who was shot down in 1952 over
the Sea of Japan Mary the first thing
I'd like to say is that I'm so thankful
that bill Burroughs wrote this book
because it's after all these years of
you know people not being interested and
and people not even knowing what the
Cold War was having read my story in
here I no longer feel invisible I just
you know
all those years I felt kind of invisible
and I was even told at some point if I
just started to talk about it at once
why I said something about this is maybe
1990 and I was going through a hard time
I said something to a neighbor I said it
just bubbled up my husband's missing in
action oh that was 40 years ago forget
it get on with your life and this is
basically at the attitude with which I
was treated all those years you never
forget it but when my baby was six six
weeks old when my late has never shot
down and he was Dillman about money and
so and then the other student took we're
due to go through a permanent duty
station because he had not yet been on a
permanent duty station we were married
and six weeks later the Korean War
started and immediately his mission
changed from being you know from being a
navigator a pilot actually started out
but he washed out then he got to be a
navigator but the mission changed from
peacetime air air force to wartime and
his training was speeded up he was soon
put on a combat crew and then he shipped
out in May of 1952 and his plane was
shot down in October so I was not
established really anywhere because you
don't think about you don't think about
them die you just it's like denial
they're going into danger but it was
never dealt with in other words there
was no we wives were not ever brought
together said now look you shuffle your
husband's doing a very dangerous job oh
you know and I said he could get killed
and what are you going to do the point
is it was never addressed and even after
even after after I got that gal thenews
and it had been awhile
later some very lovely officers wives
came to visit me they always make a call
but they had nothing to offer me they
had no plans or you know support for me
or anything and I didn't know what to
ask where I had never had a husband shot
down before so and I would really like
to see people you know give some thought
to what happens to the military widows
and fatherless children I think that so
I've made them know so to help me but
anyway my late husband is the stories in
the book so I won't say too much about
it but his remains came home and there's
nothing like a military ceremony at
Arlington National Cemetery there's
nothing to compare with it and it's
wonderful and it's necessary it is good
however it's merely to me is merely a
symbol it's a symbol of the respect that
the nation has for this man who has
given his life for his country but if
that's all there is
you know if the widows in children are
just brought to the ceremony and then
ignored by the military after that to
fight their own way to fight their own
battles to survive as best they can then
you know that beautiful ceremony it's
kind of meaningless to the family
several things I'd like to see change
and one of them one of the things that
was hardest for me was being totally
alone in my situation there were other
mi a witness if air force widows but
nobody ever put us in touch with each
other so is it's unlike the the men you
know who serve in in combat or on shifts
and so forth who had their annual
reunions we were never brought together
so I have no contact with another mi a
widow to say hey you know what's it like
for you how do you feel you know do you
feel like you're going crazy like I do
you know how are you planning your life
there was no one to help me sit me down
and say you know he may come home he
might not come home so what are you
going to do you you've got to make some
sensible plans for yourself and your
child and that didn't happen um so it
was really a a very very hard time for
me let's see so I I don't
it just seems that um the widows and the
fatherless children it's as if we
disappeared after the man dies you know
we just kind of are invisible so uh at
least that's how I felt and I and and I
just had wished during those early years
before I remarried I was just wishing
that there was some man I felt
comfortable calling at 3:00 a.m. when my
basements flooding and my daughter's in
bed with a you know a fever of 103 I
didn't have anybody I felt comfortable
doing that with because no one had come
to me and say now look we're here for
you and we're here for you as long as
you need us and so that was very very
hard striving in long alone like that
so I think I mean looking back on it I
think I was very very naive I really
thought that I would get an awful lot of
support after my late husband or plane
was shot down I just thought I get it
from the military from people you know
families but people just didn't know how
to handle it I think that's I don't
think it's that people didn't care but
they've just never really addressed the
problem of military death and how to
handle it well I think that's about all
you know I need to say right now Gary
thank you very much
that was wonderful I would like to turn
now to Carlos Campbell a veteran Navy
reconnaissance officer who was a
navigator with VP Patrol squadron 22
from 1960 to 62 out of Japan went on to
become an intelligence officer with the
squadron and finally wound up in the
exalted position of Assistant Secretary
of Commerce in the Reagan administration
so Carlos has got a wide spectrum of
achievements and one of them being
surviving being jumped by MiG's
innumerable times and I mentioned in the
book what that's like in the pit of your
stomach and the nape of your spine and
hopefully he can do a little bit of
filling in on that part of history
Carlos thank you very much first of all
I want to commend professor burrows for
doing a fantastic job in writing a very
difficult book let me feel with the
audience that a lot of my squadron mates
have read the book and they are giving
him rave reviews because all of us never
expected a story like this to be told so
I really want to commend him and I would
encourage people to read the book
because it's a fascinating part of
history after I completed the naval
intelligence school I went to Patrol
squadron 22 stationed at Barbara's point
Hawaii and frankly I was just living a
kid's dream I I
probably I'm still on a high when I
think about my days in the Navy
squadrons and I was very lucky because I
got back-to-back squadron tours which is
very unusual we deployed to Marine Corps
Air Facility and Iwakuni Japan which 417
miles south of Hiroshima we operated out
of Iwakuni we operated out of Atsugi
Japan which is in the Tokyo metropolitan
area and also out of Misawa Japan this
was a great time we really would not
informed about the real dangers of what
we were involved with in fact in the
spring of 1961 a team came over from the
Pentagon and i briefed them on all of
our intercepts when we got jumped and we
showed him photographs of the Russian
pilots giving us the International non
piece on the bird that close to the
cockpit we described all of the tactics
and tried to relive part of the
experience with them one thing that I
felt kind of good about is that we never
had anybody in our squadron complain
about the anxiety that one would
experience when all of a sudden out of
nowhere you have a couple of MiG's not
just on your tail but off your wings
many of them would engage in provocative
actions because what they would try to
do they try to turn us toward the coast
because if we got close enough then they
basically could shoot us down or shoot
us up and that happened but it never
happened to us it happened in squadrons
that we relieved and ones that relieved
us so we were very very fortunate we
never thought about the danger we
thought about the job that had to be
done we were in the business of getting
electronic intelligence on Soviet radar
you can break a radar down so it has
what it called fingerprints you can look
at the frequency the pulse repetition
frequency bandwidth should say post
repetition rate bandwidth and things
like that now why do you want that
information you want that information so
if you have a war you can effectively
counter or jam
the enemy's radar so that information is
extremely important to enhance your
chances of completing an operational
mission if you get involved with
hostilities what else did we do
we collected intelligence on Soviet
submarines during the Cold War the
Soviets tried to convince the world that
they had 400 to 500 submarines we would
fly in the Sea of Japan and we would see
the Russians changing the whole numbers
on the side of the submarines because I
don't remember in World War 2 when the
British built the plywood Navy so when
the Germans would fly over and they take
pictures of you know they thought they
had something that they really didn't
have so we would get information on on
Soviet submarines we'd get information
on Soviet ships one time I happen to be
out and our crew ran smack-dab in the
middle of a Soviet ocean exercise that
basically was probably an ASW exercise
but we photographed whisky class
submarines we were one of the first
quadrants to photograph the golf class
submarines which was a ballistic missile
submarine so we got quite a bit of the
order of battle photographed typically
when we got jumped the intercepts would
not last that long they would go
anywhere from maybe seven to ten minutes
keep in mind that a patrol plane that's
Pacala driven is more efficient at lower
altitudes and a jet is more efficient at
higher altitude so if we would go low
then of course we would have an
advantage also in the most serious
incident that we had we were jumped by a
MIG out of North Korea and they had
their fire control radar on us which
means they were ready to shoot us down
but it was overcast and we were able to
go into the soup I've always told people
we went below
500 feet we probably were 50 to 75 feet
off the deck now the reason that we did
that is because it's very difficult for
a jet flying at the speed that they
would fly to pull up and if they you
know impact the water they would run
their entire afternoon
so we basically would use that as a
defense tactic again I'd like you to
think about government policy Defense
Department policy in not going after
downed Airmen now there are some reasons
which I wouldn't support but typical
scenario might be intelligence it's
really hard that says there are nine
people in a prison camp north of a place
called Seca Virage in the Soviet Far
East
and you're doing an extraction you know
proposal and it says well it's gonna
cost you 50 people to get nine out and
also you might risk war so you have
these so-called whiz kids up in the
Pentagon saying well you know this
doesn't make sense I wouldn't want to be
in the position to make that decision
because myself I would go for it and say
well we're just gonna have to kill more
of them than we lose and the United
States well as long as we're exist those
situations are going to come up I would
encourage you to read the book because I
think there's some serious policy
questions that are raised not just about
the whole issue of extractions but also
about the need to continue to exercise
vigilance and going against a potential
enemy here we have a situation now where
we can use non pilot aircraft to collect
intelligence let me just close by saying
I was very lucky after the two squadron
tours and the Naval Postgraduate School
I got has got us back to the Defense
Intelligence Agency headquarters again
you get a lot more of the big picture
and there we I couldn't say this without
probably getting shot or arrested back
in 1965
we use the the we use satellite
photography I was a chief target analyst
wall of Soviet labor installations so
words I mean I when I went through
college I never thought I could
pronounce Vladivostok more let's look at
it but look so you know places like
Vladivostok and Olga Bay and Petri and
you know Sevastopol and all these other
places you that's what you're looking at
that was an exciting position to have
because I think that the United States
from a technology standpoint has really
done an incredible job in staying ahead
of the curve notwithstanding recent
glitches in the era of human
intelligence but from a technology side
I think that countries made a tremendous
leap and professor burrows wrote deep
black which goes onto the even side of
that out of the National Security Agency
so I'd encourage you to read this raises
a lot of issues about policy I think the
people that did this and I say
particularly the families the wives and
the children the anxiety that they
experienced I think puts them in the
hero category in heroine category
because they had to live in a situation
where their fathers and their husbands
couldn't share with them what they were
doing and one of the things about life
is you know meaning what you do is of
great significance so imagine that so
basically that's all I have to say it is
quite a lot what's been going through
our mind right now is that this has
amounted with the two of you here this
is amounted to an oral history and very
valuable in its own sake I would say a
couple more things in closing one is
this is the tenth book I've written and
in the course of the other nine I have
made a lot of really great acquaintances
this remains the only book I've ever
written where I have made lasting
friends and for that I am deeply
grateful of to you people finally I
would like to say that this ain't just
history it is current events
when Shane Osborn ran into our vice
versa
that authentic Chinese hot dog here at
Hainan Island on April 1st and had to
land with his crew that he was on one of
these missions the Navy was flying it
and it's important to note that as soon
as those people were released by the
Chinese the Air Force rivet joint
program picked it up to show the other
side that we weren't going to get chased
out of there that the rate that the
reconnaissance was just as important now
as it was during the Cold War and what
you're not reading coming out of
Afghanistan is we're still doing it and
as an old newsman I can't help but make
the remark that when you lose 30 or 40
planes on a mission that's news as when
a house falls down that's news when you
don't lose any planes on a mission
that's not news but some of us know that
the reason our losses have been very
light against Iraq and in Kosovo in 99
and now in Afghanistan is because the
recce guys the intelligence collectors
were there first flying the shadow
missions out of sight of the rest of the
world and with no recognition at all so
they're still doing it and a lot of
lives
are owed to these very brave very quiet
heroes and I guess I guess that's it
thank you